yeah all right wear and tear on player
body something we talk about all the
time how about this wrinkle as it
relates to the team that has emerged as
really the best sustained franchise in
league history New England Patriots over
the last six years have played seven
full football seasons 16 extra games via
the postseason played in six years that
is amazing to me and you know what
that's another argument that maybe the
NFL can point to a couple of
regular-season games
Patriots had a couple of regular season
games minimum every year they've played
an extra full season over the last six
that and they're and they're surviving
and they're thriving ya know they're yes
they are now New England's cutting edge
in all areas training you know Bill
Belichick is always looking for new ways
to practice you know maximize everything
he can do in the day I know they've
really improved their facilities up
there you know we've heard the coaches
have the you know those sleeping
chambers where they can go and Pires can
use them so they're obviously doing
something right I know the NFL will be
able to point towards that but this is
New England they're different than the
other 31 organizations in football
they've kind of proven that they're on a
different level when I first read this
Mike really the first thing I thought of
was wow that's such a testament to the
Patriots okay and just their their
mental toughness their physical
toughness we are the ultimate
fourth-quarter team we talked about how
they run wind sprints right late in the
season
unlike most teams but what here is this
for Brady how many years is he played a
playoff football that's where I didn't
look this up because I didn't know we
were gonna do this right here at PFT
Otzi but I'd like to see how many years
has he extended beyond with just the
playoff times because it's I mean that
it's unbelievable that's a great point
that's a great point cuz they were in
the playoffs oh one right oh three oh
four oh five OH six oh seven he was
injured in oh eight right and then every
year since 2009 they've been in the
postseason I mean I got to think it's
the next 40 games 40 games to have more
seasons two and a half more seasons two
already an unbelievably long career that
that's amazing
for Tom Brady as well but it just got
mean I'm not surprised by anything
are you I mean New England is just so on
a different level you said it it's it's
the greatest domination of two decades I
can ever remember not only in football
but I mean I think in any sport I mean
it's is it passing the Celtics of the
50s and 60s now I don't know it's up
there right well and when you consider
how things are set up so there isn't and
won't be a dominant team the fact that
they are as dominant as they've been
yeah makes it even more impressive
I mean basically Bill Belichick has
cracked the code on every competitive
edge he does everything within the
confines of the rules for the most part
although we've had a couple of incidents
in the past and who knows what to really
make of any of that but for the most
part 99.9% it's been figuring out what
the rules are and how to use the rules
to your advantage how to use the
calendar your advantage how to do
everything you can to get your guys
healthy keep them healthy get them ready
get them prepared and go out and win
football games and then within the
confines of those games situational
football doing what you have to do Chris
to automatically provide in the one
statistical category that matters points
scored versus points allowed that's
right that's it and the Patriots keep
finding a way to do it yes they do and
and you know and and that's the one
thing I learned you know in my short
time up there it's always not only
detailed but not like set in their ways
details right if there's oh you bring a
better way a more concise way of doing
something thinking of something they're
all for it and that's where Bill
Belichick I think it's amazing to me
because you know he's old-school he's a
curmudgeon but he's very welcoming of
the new school and the new ways and
looking for new things and that's really
why he's the ultimate testament to old
school is doing that you're right they
do the old school you're right they
always look for ways to get ahead of the
competition so it's not just hey we're
gonna do the single wing for the next 50
years it is here's what we do now but
we're always looking for something
better we can do and is there somebody
out there doing something better that we
can do so it's that constant not just
creativity because you do come up with
your own ideas but it's that constant
willingness to take things that other
teams have figured out that are working
for them so you almost have to have that
it's almost like a lack of shame where
you will steal any idea
yeah that you can find if you can make
it work for your team ultimately it's 11
on 11
you have only so many resources they
have only so many resources and you do
what you can and the Patriots have
figured it out unlike anyone else and
it's you know we spend the offseason
talking about this team in that team and
maybe they can turn around maybe they
can turn it around at the end of the day
yeah I just feel like we're gonna be
talking about the Patriots all over
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports